York entertain is a parliamentarian and
a member of the German Foreign Policy
Committee and joins us now mr. teen how
did this revenue to mask our effect
german foreign policy it changed it in
total until that time the only
legitimation for using military force
what if was a tea defense of the country
with the decision that the war or a DD
factum that war was back in Europe
Germany decided to be prepared for
missions under the roof of the United
Nations under the roof of the US said II
to avoid atrocities and to avoid ganna
side and for the first time in Bosnia
German soldiers went to a so-called
out-of-area mission mr. chetan you
disagreed with the former foreign
minister yashka fishery he argued in
favor of German military intervention in
Kosovo his argument was never again
genocide how do you see it now that's
not really true we had a dispute under
question whether Germany could be part
of the mission in Bosnia but in the
moment as we have faced the problems in
Sabourin nature and we came to
government and 98 it was a unit unity
decision of the cabinet at that time
that that what happened in rabbinate
should not be repeated in Kosovo and
later on on Montenegro and that was the
reason why the government I was member
of decided to go on the intervention in
Kosovo and later on on Montenegro let's
talk about a current day Germany how
willing is the country to take military
action with threats today from the is
for instance or in African conflicts i
can southern Sudan where there is
potential genocide we are part of
diverse international missions were on
that roof of the United Nations from
from the fighting piracy in the coast of
Lebanon in the south of Sudan we were in
we facing a new mission in the Central
African Republic but we learned
second thing after severing the chain
these two decades the second is that are
our limits of interventions not every
intervention succeeded and amazed
obvious problem with an intervention was
the French UK mission in Libya that
destroyed the country and left over a
failed state with two companies and a
lot of vacuum used by Isis so you have
to be aware if you decide on such a
mission that you need a political
solution and you need at the end the
political outcome in the case of Bosnia
in the case of balcon we had as it was
the progress of getting to European
Union in cases like Libya where there's
nothing like a political solution is at
the end these military missions failed
okay mr. Chien we have to leave it there
thank you so much for joining us thank
you